[Music]
let's look at this lynnium ID so I have
Firefox version 54 with selenium ID so
let me show you that this is what my
firefox says and then that I have
selenium ID I can go to tools and click
on selenium ID when I do that it shows
me this
it shows me window like this this is how
it looks on the Mac
and now in this I have a disc is by the
name of it's a default desk is by the
name of untitled if you do that I click
on the status and go to properties you
can rename this disc is easy and can
give it a name test case one
and press cookie so the name of the
deceased will be changed
second this is how you can you know
rename the diskless if you want to add a
new test case you can do the right-click
and say in this case and a new test case
will be added by the name of one title
and you can rename it again if you want
to switch between your test case you can
simply double click on it and you will
be switched second by default when you
open the selenium ID this is my
recording button this is my recording
button if you click on this recording
button sorry when you open it by default
in recording States it's by default and
recording a state if you want to stop
the recording you'll need to click on it
so let me first the coffee of the steps
and then I will show you that how the
steps are coming up okay so I have click
on it it's in regarding seat now I'll go
ahead and write here google.com when I
write google.com I can come here and can
write selenium HQ dot for G and press
this Google search button
when I click on this it shows me you
know this Google search page where I
click on one link I can click on
documentation where look on
documentation it opens up something this
page so everything whatever I have there
what I did so far is recorded in my
right there if you see and now you can
stop the recording and can see that what
the steps it has regarded first of all
it has opened the URL in the URL it is
showing me this thing okay you know
backslash GFE etc etc because the base
URL is present right here
and after that what you want to enter in
the base URL this because when you open
google.com in like if I if I just click
here and open google.com so this is my
beach URL and pose that is by custom URL
you can see
you
you
after that yes it has clicked on these
search box it is clicked on this search
box after clicking on search box no no
no no I let's see okay where it has
clicked
so if you want to see where it has liked
what you can do is you can select the
step okay and let me move it somewhere
so they can see
it is short
and click on this find
you
no nowhere that has clicked because it
has used the CSS I can check but I live
for it so I am just checking
where it has clicked but I will tell you
that how we can check at a later stage
when we will learn locators the time
being I am checking with my
you
it has not been found right here so I
can simply delete it from this step
because I don't know from where it has
added this step CSS this
so I can simply delete it if they want
and would lead that I can press I can do
the right-click and can say delete
delete the system if I you want to add
some step we can again right-click and
say insert new command and here you go a
new step will be inserted
so far so far let's talk about
these three steps so first is D command
that is open so there can be multiple
commands in selenium ID and
if you want to see the rest of the
commands then these are the list of the
commands we are actually not many many
commands
okay
you
but beyond using open command to open
this particular URL so what the URL we
will have to open we have mentioned that
in the target this is the target if you
want to even change it you can simply
change it as well if I want to change it
I guess NPC done so you need to you know
there's no separate action you need
these six boxes are editable and you can
simply change it if you want the next
one we have is T type this is the type
command which is we going to type on the
browser so whatever you want to type on
the browser you use type command format
the target is ID equals to LST I be okay
what is this target remember yesterday
we talked about seven locators and one
of the locator is ID and the ID value is
LS div so we'll be talking about the
locators for the time being you can
ignore this locator because you will be
a means you will be having understanding
of locators once we will learn it and
then you can if you want to change the
locator you will be able to change it as
well
and push that there is a value that you
are using type command for that we need
target as well as value so what value do
you want to give do you want to give
selenium edge Peru towards your what if
you want to change it again its editable
and you can simply change it to selenium
HQ and done
who's that we have click and wait
selenium HQ when you search for selenium
HQ and it is one command missing there's
one test if missing if you remember
let me tell me which step is missing
from this
anyone
absolutely Susie so that's the step
which is missing that is clicking on the
search button Google search button okay
so that's what what we have deleted it
might deletion the Google search button
into ADEs on that so let me just check
whether it is related to that or not
you
you
yeah it was it was the sweater only
which is coffee not and it just you know
if you can see the use of inium ID you
must have observed that it has not
recorded the step correctly or not
align the steps correctly because that
click was listening on the second step
but it should come after typing the
value okay so let me just add the step
now and at the right place so I will say
click and wait at what I say that I will
use input dot LS me and
I need to write the thesis as well that
I am using CSS for this and this is the
one hand up and after that click on it
and here we have the documentation we
are clicking on the documentation link
if we have if there that's documentation
link is not present and it will of
course through us an error an error in
the form of a red color that you know
this escapes could not be could not run
audio disk is this field okay so let me
tell you about these steps once again we
have this is a base URL which it
mentions always when it negates you any
site after that what if you want to open
this is the open command this is the
command this is the target and this is
the value if you want to see that
whether it what all things it accepts
what all things open command accept what
all things type command accepts you can
select that command and can see here in
the reference that type with the locator
as well as with the value so it means
two things one is located and one is
value because you are writing the value
at what location okay you are using the
locator so that's why we use target as
well as value here but clicking it as
you can see here in the reference it
only needs locator so I went to the
locator right here
after that if you want to debug if you
want to debug any of the test case you
can double click on that particular test
case so here I am going to you can see
it's in gray color and if I double click
on it
it has clicked on the page and here you
can see it has it is in green color now
so this is what we call raj debugging in
selenium ID this is what we called as
debugging in selenium ID
also if you want to see so this is in
the form of a table and if you want to
see in the HTML code it's in the power
of this it's a complete HTML code what
you are seeing right here in source you
can see that second so either you edit
them right here or you edit them in the
source that's perfectly fine there is no
harm all the things what you execute
gets logged in the log okay and you will
see that what logs are being maintained
here if you want to execute your test
case what you have recorded okay what
you can do is you can simply click on
this button here you can see this button
with a single you know highlighted green
horizontal line if you click on this
button it will play the current selected
taste keys and the left button will run
a complete test so whatever that is case
you have in this particular ID you know
on the left here whatever test is there
you have if you want to run all of them
then you will press this button else you
will press the first button so let me
press this and let's see then so if I
press it it goes to Google it interests
lien image Q and then it was not able to
click on Google search button here you
can see and if I go back to sleep ID and
see person third here you can see that
it was not able to click on this click
and wait and you can see it's in green
red color now and here is the report run
is one and failure is also one this is
how it shows you reporting reporting is
of course not good but as you can see
that it is getting filled why because
when it is starts typing this it takes
few milliseconds but it is much faster
that before when it was typing it starts
looking for this and when it does not ok
when it you know then find this
particular locator it shows me an error
that I am not able to find this locator
so just
see if you have used the correct locator
or not in this case what we do we have
to put ugly actually we have to put a
weight because so that we can give
enough time for this particular type
command to run completely and then wait
and then click on the search button
Google search button ok
so those things will not be added
automatically by selenium that's what
you need to add yourself so you can do
right-click insert new come on and
here's let's see if we have any command
for weight so weight for
so let's see what all wait commands we
have wait for condition wait for
confirmation with for cookie wait for
element let's see wait for locator wait
for target if we have wait for locator
app erm wait for element if we have so
there is one command that is wait for
element present we are checking whether
the Google search element is present or
not checking whether this particular
element is present or not what this
vehicle element present is needing it
needs a locator that what element are
you looking for for which you want wait
so I say that I am looking for this
element wait for this particular element
this one and so I put a wait now and
let's see if it works again let's run it
I run the ad it runs it enters and here
we go it's working perfectly fine now
okay let me tell you four more times in
the selenium IDE now the one the best
part of this little mighty whatever you
have recorded here so first of all when
do you use selenium ID what do you think
I have mentioned that little one like
name Bush and the companies don't use
later my ID will be precise okay but
when we should use actually the selenium
IDE what do you think in this case
you see any benefit of using selenium
IDE
and where do you think that you can use
the selenium IDE
the check controls being recorded
properly but the ugly means I am my
question is like when do you think that
you should use selenium ID whether you
should use it or not like checking
controls I be recorded properly I would
say
because in future we do need to record
things
we'll have to write our script in you
know in Java completely and we may not
go to selenium ID for this purpose okay
so I think that's more than enough so to
be precise as you know that yesterday I
have to do selenium from Firefox 55
selenium IDE you have seen the behavior
yesterday it didn't work so of course
you have to work without selenium ID
first of all always you'll have to work
on without selenium ID second this
selenium IDE be used to use it only to
create prototype of tests so what
happens is you know you get an
application and your manager say is
whether it can be automated with your
tool what you are using like selenium on
model so if the manager sees whether you
can automate this application using
selenium or not instead of winglets lips
and writing the script you can certainly
go to selenium ID and then start
recording at particular steps whatever
you are following on that website and if
they are getting recorded if they are
getting recorded then you can see that
yes it can be automated using selenium
else know so you can see it as it is
used to create the type of test you can
see if you have a smallest automation
script then you can use selenium ID and
it can also be used to identify elements
that you will record the steps so we'll
get all the locators right at this
location and you can use these locators
then in your script or wherever you want
so these are the few benefits of using
selenium ID also there is one more thing
of selenium ID which is when you open
the selenium ID and you would file
because you can save your disk is it
will be saved in be dot HTML format you
can export the taste keys in any form
you can whatever steps you have recorded
you can convert them into a scripting
language so you can convert them into
Java
shop Python Ruby also you can convert
them to webdriver
to the remote-control component anyone
what is mentioned here nuna unit test ng
these are the unit testing framework and
like remember yesterday I told you that
you don't need to install the unit
testing framework as of now because we
will be talking about unit testing
framework at the later stage so this is
the unit they export a skis as did this
it will ask you that where do you want
to save it what name you want to say
with us I will say it has test and save
and I can simply go to Amanda Dexter
so here we go if you see this it is
converted your code into ask thing
language here you can see that
diabolical new Firefox driver base URL
is Google Doc or dot n then this is a
weight which we'll be talking about
today then base URL then optic sign
grammar to find elemental locator so
everything has been converted into this
but you know there are certain why we
don't export these zero why don't we
record and export these scripts into
this Java language and then use it
because first of all the motive of
learning selenium is to create an
automation framework and an automation
framework will not be going to write a
script like this
also selenium IDE adds few extra things
in this like a selenium is allowed
present closed and lured and gated 6 etc
all those things ok so it adds some
extra functionality which we don't need
actually so why to increase the core
when we don't use it so this is how you
can also convert your recorded script
into a yes script into the JavaScript as
well there is one more thing which I
want to tell you that is this test case
what you have recorded you can also
schedule them so there is one scheduled
button which you can click and can say
we want to schedule it yes I want to
schedule it on which day do you want to
schedule it so you mention that I want
to run them on Sunday Monday Tuesday
etcetera after that you say at what time
at what minute and then you select you
know you select the test case or the
desk suit that you want to run at that
particular time so you select that from
here so what happens here first first
you save your scripts by going to file
save test case after that you come here
and say yes I want to create a job and
select that particular test case which
you want to run and done you press ok
and after pressing ok you will see all
the jobs will be less set right here and
all the activities what will happen will
be listed right here it will run your
particular script at that particular
time and done but guys if you want to
use this Linda mighty ready to downgrade
your Firefox important thing and when
more information I have got today that
is they have deprecated or they have a
stopped updating selenium ID but they
are working on one tool which is a
record and play tool for selenium which
may launch soon
you
okay one more thing which I want to
mention that this web driver remember
yesterday Anthony or someone has said
that we can run this Firefox we can run
selenium ID on Firefox and Chrome when I
mentioned that it you can run the
selenium ID only on Firefox but you can
run your scripts on chrome and ie as
well so that's what I was mentioning
here so here we have so what happens is
in selenium ID we have one option that
is called as the driver if you enable
this web driver and mention your Jaco
driver part okay really is your Jaco
driver if you mentioned that and you
press ok and you run it what will happen
it will execute your complete script in
your groom in your Firefox whatever you
will mention here in Chrome and Firefox
in Internet Explorer wherever you want
to run them just me need to mention it
right here ok so this is what I have for
selenium ID because that's more than
enough how I feel for selenium ID for
now and if there is a new tool comes of
course it will come up with some new
functionalities hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos turner up and get
certified click here
[Music]